Duran has George Hill mismatch there  James looking out Durant spins the other  way and gets his first bucket how  sensational was he in Game three take  away the threes make them play inside  the arc  it's been tough thus far James misses  the layup and Durant wide open down the  other end the quick pass ahead and  Tehran Luke calls yet another timeout as  the lead is up to 11 Duran cuts inside  court just passed there from draymond  Green they better get their defense  going Durant  spins jump shot is good Kevin Durant now  4 of 6 from the field  Duran has the mismatch with Hill shot  clock at 8 now Smith picks him up on the  switch Durant finds some room drills it  Kevin Durant with 14 to shoot JR Smith  on Durant Durant finds some space jump  shot is up  soft touch bounces in and this will be  their sixth straight win to close out  the season and get themselves another  championship  Durant banks at home 20 points for  Durant